it was a virus that destroyed lives and
livelihoods its Legacy will be felt for
years to come
Ranjit chandrabala was a London bus
driver one of 27 to die from covid-19 in
the first three months of the pandemic
his daughter leshi expects answers
he contracted covert in April so
had you know certain measures been in
place you know at his Depot and on his
buses maybe he would still be alive he
was definitely left exposed he had no
PPE to speak of they gave him
um gloves and that was it and hand
sanitizer
from this evening I must give the
British people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home decisions made
during the pandemic are about to come
under intense scrutiny for the first
time in our history the government is
going to step in and help to pay
people's wages we've tried to throw a
protective ring around our Care Homes
it's a process that will take years and
cost at least tens of millions of pounds
this inquiry is going to go much deeper
than simply weighing up one policy
Choice against another it's going to
look at the government's conduct during
the pandemic and ask if that matched
what the country would reasonably expect
from its leaders in a time of crisis
soon the focus will be on the
government's decision making including
policies such as eat out to help out
pushed by the then chancellorishi sunak
which has been criticized by some
government advisors
so taking your foot off the break is one
thing but putting your foot on the
accelerator of the epidemics was in my
view a very different thing and um
couldn't see any any reason for doing it
that you know I just think thought that
at the time that it would
Kickstart the next way the inquiries
opening has been overshadowed by Boris
Johnson's resignation from Parliament
following an investigation into alleged
lockdown breaches and the controversy
over government WhatsApp messages
but for bereaved families nothing must
be allowed to distract the inquiry as it
begins its search for the truth oh she's
Josh he's Sky News